Good morning, Hank! It's Tuesday. So I just turned 40, which you'll be unsurprised to learn has led to a bit of existential navel-gazing.
But not with the conclusions that one might expect. So when I was younger, not just like in my teens,
but also through my twenties,
I thought of adulthood as like an ending. Like, in my imagination, human life was this epic road
trip that started when you were born and ended when you reached your destination:
adulthood. And once you arrived at adulthood
you were never allowed to leave. To me, adulthood meant being weighed down with all these
responsibilities. You have to mow the lawn, and take your kids to soccer practice,
and pay your bills on time because you care about something called your credit score. And from what I could tell about adulthood, these
responsibilities would sort of pin you down and prevent you from growing or changing and you would just become a robot that fulfills
obligations. You know, I thought it was like an existential death that came several decades before your actual
physical death. So to delay the onset of adulthood and the metaphysical death that came with it,
my strategy in my twenties was to keep my life very light and lean. Like one time
I remember saying to a girl
I was dating, that if I needed to, I could pack my life up into my car in 15 minutes.
She dumped me shortly thereafter. Now of course, I couldn't pack up my wall of memorabilia in 15 minutes,
let alone my whole life. And of course,
I'm gonna tell you that I was underestimating adulthood because I have to, right?
Adults can't think of adulthood as a prison from which there is no earthly escape.
We have to trick ourselves into thinking that we're having a great time and not at all being slowly strangled to death by homeowners
association meetings. And who knows? Maybe I am tricking myself, but for the record, I love being in a place
that's hard to leave.
I like having roots in a place and friends I've known for 25 years.
And that wasn't possible 20 years ago because, you know, I hadn't been alive for 25 years. Now sometimes I do feel
overwhelmed by the obligations of adulthood. But even so, I would not want to be 15 again or for that matter 25.
I know that's easy for me to say because I've been incredibly lucky in both my professional and personal lives.
But I know a lot of middle-aged people who are leading a wide variety of lives
and I honestly think that my experience is more the rule than the exception.
Adulthood is so underrated
But more importantly, it turns out that adulthood is not a destination. Like I don't think my life has grown less
interesting as it has grown more settled.
I used to think that nothing stank of failure quite like living in the suburbs with your spouse and your two kids, that such an
existence was a tremendous waste of what Mary Oliver called "your one wild and precious life."
But I find at 40 that my life feels
wilder and more precious than ever. That's not to say that my way of being an adult is the only good way
or that it's right for everyone. It's just that it's right for me. And if this is 40, I'll take it.
Thanks so much to everybody for their birthday wishes and turtle cakes. Three more things. First: look, look, look, look, look!
I have finished signing all
200,000 copies! And the boxes are gone! Those
200,000 sheets of paper are now at the printer in Virginia being bound into copies of "Turtles All The Way Down."
Amazon and barnesandnoble.com have both sold out of their allotment of signed copies,
but there is still lots of other ways to get them. More info at probablysignedturtles.com.
Secondly, my video next week will be me reading the first chapter of  "Turtles All The Way Down."
That video will be over four minutes,
but that is not
punishable. There are precedents set in 2011 and 2008 when I read the first chapters of "The Fault In Our Stars" and "Paper Towns." And
lastly, I want to say to our friends and viewers affected by flooding in Texas and Louisiana
and also in India, Nepal, and Bangladesh that we are thinking of you. Nerdfighters, if you're able,
I hope you'll join me in donating to relief organizations. There are links in the Doobly-Doo below. Hank, I will see you on Friday.